from brian i came out to my family about
my sexuality recently
i revealed to them that i'm a
gender-rigid half-bisexual
half-bisexual
gentle man what a great line my pronouns
are
i'm not such a towering rabid malignant
narcissist
that i expect the rules of the english
language to change to accommodate me and
my unique identity
they don't seem receptive to my new
identity do you think they're being
unreasonable thanks yes they are
they're being very intolerant very
close-minded and i say this i guess i'll
come out right now on the show too
i say this as a gender-rigid
half-bisexual myself
don't worry it gets better it gets
better okay you are seen
you are heard and your pronouns that's a
beautiful pronoun i love that not being
a malignant narcissist wow
that's great my best to you and your
family i hope they i hope they can come
around
hey if we're still on youtube i am
absolutely shocked
because we really broke the narrative
today because the studies broke the
narrative if you want those sorts of
facts that you're not going to hear from
the left-wing sources
subscribe ring that bell like it and
head on over to apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher
myspace live journals and guide we're on
all the platforms subscribe to the
michael knowles show please leave a five
star review we really appreciate that
helps us break through the walls of
censorship and suppression and get right
to you we'll see you next time
[Music]
you